the secret behind a great Eggs Benedict
is in the hollandaise so get your pan on
cause I'm gonna cook the hollandaise
over a rolling boil with a glass bowl
butter to put on to melt three egg yolks
separated from the white tarragon
vinegar pop that into the eggs you
cannot get tarragon vinegar any white
wine vinegar will do just as long as you
got that acidity in there get some bike
to hollandaise put your bowl over the
rolling water and just start whisking if
the eggs have direct contact with the
gas hollandaise will become scrambled
egg once you got that nice creamy
texture a nice thick Savion start adding
your butter nice and slowly couple of
tablespoons of butter in it
and give that a really nice mix
you don't whisk it enough the egg yolks
don't take the butter it causes it to
split it's more butter using a big
balloon whisk like this one makes it
easier to incorporate air and helps
prevent your mixture from separating all
the butter in and the best way to keep
hollandaise nice and warm is just leave
it to sit over that nice warm water bath
and it just keeps that a really nice
room temperature a nice pinch of salt
fresh pepper and then place lemon juice
that just really makes it vibrant
exciting you want it like a sort of
thick custard I just want it to coat the
back of the spoon so it's like you're
giving them a nice glossy texture to
your beautiful poached egg now as the
base for the Eggs Benedict
you cannot beat English muffins but the
ham and will change I'm gonna use the
most amazing Parma ham get your pan nice
and hot into the pan it's like posh
rashes of bacon
Paulo ham fried nice and crisp by that
is incredible
beautifully salads fantastic for Eggs
Benedict
[Music]
now keep that pan nice and hot on all
that flavor on the Parma ham left in
there
and rather than toast my muffins I want
to put the muffins into the pan I'm
sucking up all that wonderful flavor
from that crispy Parma ham make sure
your muffins are toasted nicely
this will prevent them don't soggy later
your that nice and crisp that water on
to boil for the eggs nicely seasons
really important and it's a little
splash of vinegar in the water that
helps to set the egg white in the minute
you crack it in while the water heats up
in the pan there's time to get organized
lay a nice slice of ham on the base now
waters brought up to the ball turn it
down and then spin your water around
like a little Worldport then getting a
little cup so you just dropped the cup
in a local hands to the egg gets caught
up in the turbulence of the water the
secret it's not the ball the water
rapidly because the strength of the ball
can literally explode your egg as they
start to move the way up to the top of
the water
that's a indication that they're cooked
take off any excess little bits of egg
white and then out onto a piece of
tissue paper that just drains off excess
water and it stops your muffin from
getting really soggy look they're like
little beautiful mozzarella balls give
them a little season lift them on to
your crispy Parma ham beautiful
now get a nice spoon of your hollandaise
lays over try and do it in one blazing
over the whole egg when I tell Jack
Holli Megan and Matilda that we're
cooking eggs benedict for breakfast they
bolt down the stairs and let's be honest
who wouldn't run to sit in front of
those
[Music]
a special-occasion breakfast that would
make anyone feel spoiled eggs benedict
with crispy Parma ham
beauties
[Music]